So speaking of things that, uh, didn't follow a perfect theory, a model,
a JavaScript. So there's two things, one, it had an impact on the world,
a huge scale.
Obviously it is also still is one of probably the
most popular programming language in the world.
So can we go back to the origin story? Uh,
can you tell the story of how JavaScript was created?
Yeah. I was at Silicon graphics after graduate school for seven years
and it got to be big and successful and divisionalized and political,
and I thought I'm kind of boring.
And a friend who'd been there went to, uh,
one of the last of the super companies, super startups in,
in the early nineties. There were several, I suppose,
general magic was a little after that, around the same time.
But micro unity was that company that I went to and it was because my friend,
Jeff Weinstein had gone there for Silicon graphics.
He recruited me and my community was doing everything. So this was,
this was like the ultimate sort of pretend grad school. It was doing a new fab,
new semiconductor process. It was doing new, um,
analog and digital circuits on the same, very large, but not wafer scale chip.
Um, originally it was, um, five centimeters on a side. Let me see.
It was really hot too. So I needed a water cooler. Um, it was a crank Hiller,
and then they shrunk it and they tried to do a home sort of media processor that
was essentially a barrel processor. But you could think of, um,
trying to do all the things that we now see in modern architectures with short
vector instructions and, um,
sort of wide instructions or multiple issue, uh, and,
and doing a lot of this stuff in software because the second iteration,
the set-top box was really for avoiding the cost to the cable company of rolling
the trucks out to replace your garbage general Atlantic set-top box with a
totally new or less, less a garbage one. So if you could have software gradable,
um, set-top boxes, the cable companies, uh,
thought they could save a lot of money and add features.
This is assembly or which level.
We were riding in, in. Um, we were using GCC,
we're getting C plus plus and C uh, somebody I, I worked with there, um,
really smart guy hired from a sort of wall street. Um,
hot shot programming consultancy did his own hardware design as well as
software. And we were working on how to make, uh,
not only these short vector units, but general bit shufflers per meters.
So you could do things like, um, uh, you know, crypto algorithms efficiently,
and you could do, uh, the modulation of the cable, you know, complex, uh,
quadrature, amplitude modulated signal. So you were basically taking, uh,
add converters, dumping things in buffers,
and then doing the rest of the software, all the framing and the Reed,
Solomon and Viterbi and all that aircraft.
So that was really great learning experience, but it was not going to work.
It was doing too many risky things at once, right? If you, as Clark said to me,
when I hopped to Netscape after three years at Mike Rian and he said, Oh yeah,
you'll do 10 things. Each one in 10 odds, it's going to be one in 10 million.
Um, the multiplication principle. So, you know,
that scape was already a rocket and I passed the chance to go there in 1994.
I knew the founders cause I worked at SGI Clark's company.
Could you pause for a second and Netscape? When was the launch of this rocket?
What? Uh, 94 94 was the launch of Netscape. And.
I went there in early 95 in April.
Okay. But, Oh, so you said you missed the launch.
The, the, the first floor employment opportunity, but the IPO was,
was August, 1995. So I was there for.
How obvious was it? The nest Cape was like world changing.
What was the layout was an one of the first big browsers. Yeah.
Yes. So when, when I was at micro unity still in 93,
we saw a browser called mosaic and up until then we'd used email and we'd used
Usenet, the NITV protocol we use newsreaders. We used FTP.
We used all these old internet protocols,
all relying on the DNS and TCP and UDP for that matter. Um,
when I was at Silicon graphics, we brought up the whole stack, right? We had to,
you know, discover how,
how to find the ethernet addresses on your network and then find IP addresses
for them, our protocol, all that stuff.
And it was great because nobody knew in the eighties what was going to win all
the proprietary stacks like IBM SNA and deck net,
and all these other protocols were saying, we're going to do it,
or it's going to be heterogeneous future. And instead it was, you know,
Berkeley Unix and the TCP IP stack that dated back to the ARPANET, that one.
And I think we knew it. We all knew it at SGN, but the salespeople didn't.
And so they kept trying to get multiple networks next interoperating,
but in the end, uh, it won.
And so that was the internet and it was email and texting and it was used that
very texting. And then, uh, Tim Berners Lee did his thing,
but I don't think I was paying attention.
And I think the date when he first did it,
or when he wrote the famous email has been pushed back to 89.
But I noticed a mosaic in 93 because one of the things that Mark Andreessen
and Eric Bina did at NCSA was they innovated on,
on the HTML early HTML standard. They in particular,
Mark sent this email saying, Hey, everybody,
we think you'd be able to put an image in a page. And, you know,
when he sent that Eric Bean has already written the code. And, you know,
I talked to Tim Berners leaving more recently, just a few years ago.
And he was like, Oh, we had another way of doing it. And then, you know,
it didn't work out. Cause Mark shipped his in mosaic.
And this convinced me of several things.
One the internet meant there was a huge first mover advantage and
being fast, getting on first mattered a lot. And so, you know, Richard Gabriel,
uh, scheme and poetry fame has written about this, the famous century poetry,
uh, well, he's a poet, uh.
Actual poetry. He's like, no.
No. I mean, he's the founder of lucid,
which is where Jamie's the ski worked before.
And that scape and lucid was doing, you know, compilers and lucid Emacs,
which was a fork of BMX famously Jamie fighting against, uh,
Richard Stallman stall max. Um, so Richard Gabriel, you know, very,
very brainy computer guy, but also a poet,
but he wrote a nice essay that gets abused all the time. In fact,
Jamie's put a kind of warning in front of his version of it on his site, JDBC,
another, there were called worse is better.
And this is about survival advantage of software in a networked world.
In my opinion, it's about Unix. It started out being framed as unison lists,
good news, bad news, because all the lists people, the MIT people were like, Oh,
you know, this is the crown Juul, right? A scheme.
This is fabric AA or common list. This giant cathedral, of course,
we're going to win. This is civilization. You know,
those farmers in New Jersey to borrow from the Sopranos,
those pigs down at bell labs. They're just, you know,
there's nothing sound there. It's all hacking. Um, well guess what one.
You, you're saying, this is a fundamental,
like principle of the internet is moving fast wins.
You could say in, in almost any network system, like biological evolution,
you see successful ilial sweet populations and they don't always have, um,
you know, they aren't free of flaws, heterozygous advantage, right?
You can get both parents, uh, give you the,
the gene variant and you get sickle cell anemia. Right. But,
but if one of them does, you're more resistant to malaria. And so this isn't,
um, a beautiful process except at large scale.
And then you realize that because it moves fast and can adapt it, it can win.
And people still struggle with this.
I used to struggle with this because JavaScript was done in such a hurry.
And the force of web compatibility meant early mistakes couldn't be fixed.
And even the standards process injected new mistakes as well. Uh,
but often standards bodies go back and making compatible changes.
You can't do that with the web. It's more like, again, like biology, you,
you preserve what still works.
You don't want to break ATP metabolism or whatever. So, um,
you have to kind of resign yourself to the reality of, um,
worse is better being enshrined in actual
design points. You might not like, um,
and that happened with JavaScript and I'm way over it. But, uh, it also,
I think was a huge advantage why JavaScript is kind of swept a lot of
programming domains. Um, people will say, Oh, it's not because of merit. Well,
you're right. But we also improved it over time in the standards body.
I spent 20 years doing that. And, uh, you don't get that choice. It's like,
I'm not saying that that was the best language.
I'm just saying that was the right time to do it.
And I like to say the alternative was not to do it. I could have told Netscape,
I can't do this. It's too rushed. And it would have been visual,
basic script would have been bad.
That's a good way to present the alternative. But so your,
it was a Netscape and you, you have written it. And how many days,
and why was it only that many days?
And what was the goal and the underlying principles in your mind?
So the whole, uh,
I'm sort of describing horses better in a frenetic way because it fit the,
the model of Netscape. When, when, um,
it was known that Jim Clark and Mark and Reese were founding Netscape and they
did the first release in 1994, that browser took over from mosaic. In fact,
that's why Mozilla is called that it's the mosaic killer.
It's like the giant monster that kills mosaic. It's awesome. And, um,
they knew that, you know, it wasn't, it wasn't that again,
it's not like you're doing advanced scientific research that is changing the
world. You're more like taking down, uh,
the last iteration in the browser market, which had images and, you know,
other affordances before you stopped working on it and you're making Netscape
the new thing that has images, plugins,
which was the way to do video back in the day,
it had something that's kind of died now for tiled windows called frames and
frame sets have yay, HTML tables. That was new.
Eric Dina did tables and Netscape one-on-one. So when I got there,
they were heading toward IPO. Clark wanted to IPO early.
I think his instinct was right. And that kicked off the whole.com era, right?
There was a recession in the U S in 91.
You can see old law and order reruns where they talk about the recession,
how hard it's hitting new Yorkers. And after that, uh,
Greenspan really goose things at the federal reserve. And,
and technology had been sort of fermenting in a way that came together with the
internet and that scape made it possible to do pets.com,
to do eBay, to get people,
to recognize a URL on a billboard and then type it in when they get home.
And that was huge. Um, that, that was so fast moving a rocket that, uh,
Mark and, um,
the engineering team there thought we need to make this a programmable browser,
not just, uh, a document viewer, not just a video.
All HTML with images and tables. And also like you said, frames,
and really the plugins, there is no dynamic element at all.
Yeah. The most dynamism you get was from a plugin,
which there are a few of them then flash didn't exist at that point. Uh, it was,
I think, um, Java applets are not well,
that's the thing we did that deal with sun. In fact,
I was recruited to go do scheme in the browser.
Remember guys stealing Gerald's husband's beautiful list variants.
I was going to do it in the browser because my friends rescue, I thought, Hey,
we like scheme you like scheme. And I'm like, I hardly ever use scheme.
It's not really used in industry except in sort of silos. Um, but I like it.
Okay. I'll come do scheme in the browser. I have a slide from my 2017,
uh,
talk where I have Bruce Wallace crawling through the duct and diehard is kind of
after the coast, the fun come on and do scheme in the browser. Um,
but when I got there,
there was no scheme in the browser because they'd started a deal with sun
Microsystems and my best contact. There was bill joy,
who I admired as a Berkeley Unix founder, and, you know, son, founder, uh,
and bill got the idea of making the browser programmable too.
And so the idea main idea was to put the job of VM,
which at that point was not really easy to embed into Netscape,
including the Netscape version of windows that was still most popular,
which was the 16 bit windows three one, which was going away.
Microsoft is coming out with windows 95 and everyone was afraid.
They were going to do you internet Explorer, I guess two, at that 0.3,
the next year they already bought, uh, or invested in somehow Spyglass,
this other company that shot out from NCSA university of Illinois.
Um, and in fact,
Microsoft had tried to buy Netscape in late 94 before I got there.
And I heard about this later, I heard they offered way too little money. And so,
you know, Jim Barksdale and Jim Clark said, get out of here pound sand,
but then they realized, Oh,
this is going to hurt us because now they're going to copy us.
It didn't happen right away.
I'm not sure when Gates internet tidal wave memo was written.
That's the famous memo he wrote when bill Gates realized that Microsoft was
going down this old copy AOL path or copy CompuServe path,
a project called Blackbird, presumably after the Sr 71, I don't know,
but they were going to make a dial up service with a custom content,
language stack and custom rendering. It wasn't the web. Um, and you know,
they could have content partners. Uh, they have a lot of money,
but it still wasn't the scale of the web.
It wasn't going to be compelling and Gates realized this and he turned the
company on a dime and they couldn't buy Netscape again. I'm not sure the timing,
so they decided to copy it.
And once we realized that everybody inside Netscape felt even more urgency and
more frenetic mood.
And so my chance to do scheme disappeared when the Java deal started brewing,
but there was still a chance to do a companion language to Java because Java was
a compiled is a compiled language it's evolved and improved quite a lot since
then, too.
But it was for sort of serious advanced programmers that cost a certain
salary or hourly rate.
And people observe bill they'll join observed and Marc Andreessen.
And I observed that in a mature stack like Microsoft,
you really benefit from having a scripting language like visual basic,
which became visual basic script and [inaudible]
, but didn't take on, didn't take over kill Java script
that you need two languages.
One is for that component writers who are higher price and more expert.
And the other is for, uh,
scripters certified public accountants, uh, designers,
graphic designers with some programming, inclination, anybody amateurs.
It doesn't matter. There's a much more demotic, uh,
approach there for programming the components together, gluing them together.
Somebody will say duct tape language, which I don't really like,
but we saw the bill joy and Mark and Vincent. And I,
we saw the need for companion language and the gleaming,
or I was to call it JavaScript. I didn't like it.
That was marketing plan Mark called it mocha, which I liked.
And that's marketing. I think didn't like that. So they said, Oh,
there's some trademark in some software somewhere that's uses mocha.
So we can't use that. And they tried live script in August and that didn't last.
And then finally we got the trademark license in December, 1985,
but the work I did to prove that it could be done was important because
I came in in April and even then Netscape was growing so fast that they
couldn't find open hiring requisition in the client team for me.
So they hired me into the server team and I worked for a month on the server
team on what became [inaudible]
. So I was actually, I had done protocol work at Silicon graphics with great
chess in a former
bell labs intern, grad student intern, who knew all the Unix founders and Greg was very interested in taking
, um,  protocols to the next level with VLSI. Uh,
cause he thought that CPS wouldn't wouldn't scale up
, he was mistaken in that. Unfortunately Moore's law more than kept up and you have gigabit ethernet running with conventional processors. But I worked on protocols at
SGI
, as well as Unix, kernel hacking and NFS and things like that. So I, I came into Netscape to work on the server side for a month, but I was, I was thinking the whole time, what should this language be like, should it be easy to use? Might it syntax even be more like natural language, like
, um,
hyper talk, which is bill Atkinson's language. And HyperCard if you had ever
used HyperCard on an early Mac. Uh,  and I thought, uh,
well, I'd like to do that. But my management saying
, make it look like Java, which looks like C from a distance. Yeah.
What does that mean? Is it braces? We're talking about visually,
do you mean like a management? Do they understand what they do?
No marketing didn't know, but, but management did like Rick shell,
the VP of engineering knew, and we had a plan even that was,
if you have this companion language,
you're going to glue things together between Java and JavaScript.
So you're going to have commerce in memory, in the heap with data types.
So you're going to want some of the data types in Java to reflect in the
JavaScript. You're going to want the primitive types of the Java,
unfortunately severed from objects.
So at least some of them number don't double let's call it.
And Java's terms from the C term for double precision floating point, um,
or strings or booleans, um,
and objects.
And so right away there was this constraint looking like Java I'm in
kind of a C curly brace syntax, but also some of the data types. Yeah.
Like objects and so on [inaudible] collection. Yeah.
Uh, even the Bitwise operators in the shift operators,
including the unsigned right shift, which Java had,
because it didn't have unsigned integer types.
It's it said if you want to do onsite operations, use an operator.
And that turned out to be important much later I'll I'll tell that story five
times, but, um, JavaScript inherited a set of, uh,
operators, the expression, grammar, the statement,
grammar up to a point from Java, but I wanted a functional language.
I wanted scheme a little bit of scheme,
even though it wasn't as clean as schema.
Well, you had to love Sergeant jobs. You had a love for scheme and list that,
that functional language landscape.
I wanted first class functions because I saw the need for callbacks in the
browser where it's a single threaded program.
All the early browsers are single-threaded and it's the right model for users.
Most users weren't ready for mutual exclusion and threading.
So in a single threaded world, you cannot block these interface.
So you have to use a callback and run later. And the, without getting too,
and trying to capture the continuation, like call CC does in scheme,
I thought I'll just make it easy to have fun arcs first-class functions.
You pass downward and it can call back. It'd be called back. Um,
and Java didn't have that at the time. It had,
it took forever to get proper first class functions Lambdas now into,
into Java Java seven or eight. I think.
It did have concurrency right from the very beginning.
But you were thinking that the JavaScript in the browser would not have the
luxury of being okay.
Correct. That's right. And the reason was Java was going to run into plugins.
We could fork threads and go, go to town.
But the main action in the browser was in the single threaded programs,
single units process on, on Unix or windows. Uh,
and it was where you had to service the event loop and then go, you know,
do things, respond to the network layout, some HTML render it, turn, you know,
with Cinda Heights, by filling containers, boxes, uh, the early,
what became the CSS box model, uh, and run scripts to, you know,
make the thing livelier respond to user input. Uh,
and all that event driven programming was in part like HyperCard because
HyperCard had this on event names, syntax.
And so that's why you have in JavaScript on click run together as the name of
the event handler. Um,
and there's some funny ones on mouse over and on mouse out.
People still complain about those, but, you know, um,
there were many more events now over the years standardized,
but it was a mix of event driven single-threaded programming because it had to
run in the main thread of the browser where the action is,
and Java never got there,
which meant Java could not interact easily or quickly or in a nested way with
the document, with the objects reflected from the HTML document,
with the tables and forms and so on. And that,
that is one of the reasons I think JavaScript survived in Java kind of die.
Java was in this plugin prison essentially was confined to a rectangle,
the applet rectangle. And while we even built a next year,
Nick Thompson friend from SGI who was an intern grad student at
CMU at the time built the first version of live connect to glue Java and
JavaScript together to deliver on that vision where you do have commerce between
the data types and the heap, um, that it worked, it worked,
but you were Java was in charge. Uh,
JavaScript was in charge and Java was just these components.
These helper augmenters, I'll do everything in JavaScript.
And what happened over time, it's like an evolutionary filter.
It just kind of who needs the plugin. And in fact, sun mismanaged,
Java as a plugin, they thought, Oh,
that scape for giving us the distribution vehicle.
We don't care about the browser. It's just about getting jobs out there.
And that was a big miscalculation.
They then tried because Microsoft was killing Netscape after years,
they tried getting into Microsoft.
And you may remember there was a sun Microsoft deal, which famously blew up and,
and, uh, Microsoft kicked Java out of windows.
And that's when they really pulled the trigger.
I think they already evaluated it and liked it on Enders,
helzberg.net and C-sharp and decided we're going to just not have Java.
W w w we don't want any of that sun stuff. We don't want the patent risk.
We don't want, I'm not sure what the all fights were about.
There was some patent angle to it, I think. And up till then,
Microsoft had been using Java components, like in outlook web access,
which had a lot of JavaScript to be a web mail, like Hotmail,
like user interface. They had to call the,
the mail server through a HDP and they, they use the, uh,
Java object to do this. And when they gave the boot to sun,
they suddenly other, you know,
the left-hand gave the boot and the right hand said,
we better do something else in outlook, web access, what are we going to do?
And they said, let's just add an active X component,
which is their own native way of embedding things in languages.
And we'll make it, uh,
it'll be what became XML HTTP request,
which is now a web standard for calling asynchronously.
And it's been replaced by the fetch API in HTML five race, you know,
living document. But this whole lineage goes back to, uh,
Java being successively, the loser and getting kicked out.
And after Microsoft kicked it out, it was a plugin.
And you would find it required for like smart card banking in,
in the Nordic countries where that was mandated by law,
but really didn't get used much. Or, you know,
there were pilots who used it for, um, flight information. Um,
but flash which Netscape could have bought, but fortunately it didn't.
Generally we would have screwed it up. I mean,
what year are we talking about with flashpoint after.
The IPO? So it was probably late 95 and.
Flash was around. Was it Adobe? No, it wasn't.
Oh, future splash. And it was a, these brothers, Jonathan Gay,
I think his name was, and he, he, uh,
came knocking and the marketing guy at Netscape who was screening the technology
partners, or want to be acquisitions was brutal.
And just everybody wanted to get it on the Netscape, you know,
stock gravy train.
And he sent them packing and they ended up selling the macro media and
Macromedia was where flash was created.
And the good thing about Macromedia was it was a, um, tool company.
So invested in, you know, the best ideas.
I think what you're still somewhat lost to us, a flash, the timeline animation,
this sort of an immutable function, uh, over time.
They had the tooling around that too. Like that dream Weaver,
there's a flash watch the director. There were a bunch of them. Yeah. I mean,
yeah, that was a flashback.
It was one of the last ones. These tools were used by real artists and,
you know, special effects people and designers,
all the restaurant websites around 2005 were done in flash, which was, you know,
we were trying to do HTML five at the same time. That was the Firefox era.
We were trying to make the web capable enough. You didn't need flash,
but if you recall, you go to a restaurant it's like,
this is kind of like a game or something.
It's like a flash or the font looks small.
He didn't like flash from the beginning. Get I could, this is,
this doesn't feel right.
I actually admire Flash's technology. I'm pretty pragmatic about these things.
And I realized that, you know, it doesn't matter if you're dealt a bad hand,
like JavaScript was a rush job.
Or if you have flash as a plugin and you can invest in the tools and make it
pretty good, uh, you should, you should make it better for your users,
grow it as best you can.
And what happened with the browser due to Microsoft monopoly abuse for which
they were convicted. And, you know, um, even after that,
until I think Firefox, and then Chrome was people kept saying, Oh,
the web can't do X. It can't do, Y we'll have to have a plugin.
We'll have to have a new approach. Well,
w w we'll clean the slate and have a new web. And everyone has said that failed.
And the reason they failed is because there's too much value in the web,
this huge network.
And the worst is better principle means that you can not only start bad,
which they all sneer at, but get on first and get wide distribution,
get sort of evolutionary advantage in priority of place,
but you can also improve it over time. And so if you're going to improve flash,
and for some reason, flash is now out of favor,
Steve jobs said you can't have flash on the iPhone.
That was probably the death nail, put your energy into JavaScript.
And that happened, right? So we, we did things at Mozilla with Adobe to improve,
which bought my Macromedia to improve flash and to improve the version of
JavaScript that was in flash. And we tried to standardize that.